have you ever wondered what happens to a
package once you take it to be shipped
we did so we rigged a camera inside a
lucite box and shipped it across the
country to follow its journey all the
way to delivery if you're sending a gift
or buying one online this holiday season
it's likely that a company like UPS will
be handling your presence at one point
or another and this season they'll be
delivering over 700 million packages
yeah places like the US Postal Service
will be delivering roughly 16 billion
cards letters and packages and it all
starts here once your package is ready
to be shipped a driver picks it up loads
it onto a truck and heads off to a
shipping home once it arrives at the hub
the package is put on a complex network
of conveyor belts where the journey
begins
but when shipping volume basically
doubles how do they keep track of it all
the short answer is a lot of automation
and technology but don't worry the
robots aren't taking our jobs as your
package zips through one of their
facilities it goes through a laser
scanning tunnel that reads the smart
label on the box and redirects it so
it's properly loaded on a truck or plane
that is headed to its destination in
this case it's going up a plane so it
has to be loaded onto an AirCam that's
fancy talk for a container built
specifically for air travel once the can
is packed to the gills it's loaded on a
plane it takes off and heads towards its
final destination UPS operates around
940 flight segments a day within the
u.s. to ensure that your last-minute
impulse buy arrives on time when the
plane arrives the air can is unloaded
and the complex dance of sorting and
scanning begins again now once the
package is loaded on the right truck the
driver heads for the final destination
and we have a pretty good idea of what
happens from here pure package opening
bliss